we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
call anytime 219 to David P speaking of
George Santos here is a caller asking a
very interesting question about the
Santos Fiasco
hey is George Santos was a Democrat how
do you think the situation would be
handled differently do you think that
Jeffries and the Democrats would be
a lot more proactive in in the same
situation I have exactly where you have
a couple seat advantage
um the Democrats have a couple seed
advantage and it would hurt their
majority and their amount of power I do
now you know this is one of those things
where when I feel that Republicans and
Democrats are basically the same I will
tell you and when I think they're
different I will tell you one of the
things that Democrats do to a fault is
they are in their effort to show
how they will not simply stand by any
Democrat no matter what sometimes
Democrats are too quick to condemn their
own a great example is the Al Franken
situation Al Franken involved in a
tasteless joke that was photographed but
what Al Franken did in retrospect
probably was not worthy of a resignation
and Al Franken resigned because there
was pressure on him to resign Anthony
Weiner Democrats abandoned him if George
Santos were a Democrat I believe there
is no doubt if he had told these lies
and about these issues that he the
pressure on him to resign would have
been total from the Democratic party and
that he would have ultimately ended up
resigning maybe to the detriment of
Democrats that is the way I have seen
Democrats operate over the last decade
in American politics so if you disagree
with me let me know but I think it would
have been handled completely differently
and Santos would be gone if he were a
Democrat and the same things were
uncovered we have such a great bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah
um on the bonus show today
it has been determined by a judge that
Ron DeSantis violated the first
amendment by removing an elected
official who was that official I will
tell you uh what we've talked about it
before we will talk about the George
Santos drag photos story because it is a
story about hypocrisy it's a story about
supposed values that they don't really
care about on the right it's a very
interesting story and by the way I
couldn't care less who's a drag queen
doesn't make a difference to me it's the
hypocrisy that is interesting to me and
we have a Challenger for Kirsten Cinema
former David Pacman show guest Reuben
Gallego is running against Kirsten
Cinema for Senate in Arizona we will
talk about what is on the table what
this means for Cinema and for Gallego
and much much more sign up at
joinpakman.com subscribe to the podcast
subscribe to the YouTube channel do the
thing and we will see you on the bonus
show or back here tomorrow